we know that the derivative with respect
to x of e to the x
is equal to e to the x which i think is
one of the neatest things in mathematics
just builds my respect for the number e
but that's not what we're here to do to
just praise e
what we really want to think about is
well what's the derivative of the
inverse function what's the derivative
with respect to x of the natural log of
x
and we've done this several times where
we know the derivative of a function and
we now want to find the derivative of
the inverse function what we can do we
can set let's say y is equal to the
natural log of x
this is another way of saying that y is
the power that we raise e2 to get to x
so this is equivalent to saying that e
to the y power is equal to x and now we
can take the derivative of both sides of
this equation with respect to x so let's
do that
the derivative of both sides with
respect to x do a little bit of implicit
differentiation really just an
application of the chain rule
and so on
the left hand side right over here this
is going to be the derivative of e to
the y with respect to y which is just
going to be e to the y
times the derivative of y
with respect to x and on the right hand
side here the derivative of x with
respect to x is 1.
and now to solve for the derivative we
just divide both sides by e to the y
so we get the derivative with derivative
of y with respect to x is equal to 1
over
e
e to the y e to the
e to the y
power
now what is y equal to well we know that
y is equal to the natural log of x
so let's write that down this is equal
to
this is equal to 1
over
e
to the
natural log of x
now what is e to the natural log of x
going to be
well the natural log of x is the power i
need to raise e to to get to x so if i
actually raise e to that power to that
exponent i'm going to get x so this is
going to be equal to
over
over let me
1 over x so this thing simplifies to x
and we are done we just figured out if y
is equal to the natural log of x the
derivative of y with respect to x is 1
over x or you could say the derivative
of natural log of x with respect to x is
equal to 1 over x
so this is equal to
this right over here
is equal to
1 over x
1 over x which is also a pretty neat
result
in
in mathematics not quite as exciting as
this one but still pretty neat